as unexpected cultural phenomena go the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles have got to
top the charts after conquering comics
and cartoons their meteoric rise
culminated in a live-action motion
picture trilogy that was an
unprecedented success so what became of
the actors who shall shocked the world I
like about you all in but I really don't
have anything to offer you guys except
for frozen pizza go for it
Donatello was voiced by a tease child
star and contemporary Wizard of
peculiarities Corey Feldman if you
haven't kept up with Feldman in the last
few years keep your arms and legs inside
the car because this gets turbulent the
Turtles franchise marked a sort of
turning point for Feldman the days of
leading roles were fading into the
middle distance gremlins and Goonies
were pretty well behind him
direct-to-video Lost Boys sequels would
be his only constant companions designer
drug unfortunately this also came at the
tail end of a contentious legal battle
with his parents who apparently spent
everything the actor made before he was
emancipated at age 15 the 90s
unfortunately seems to hit Feldman like
a train his first marriage dissolved
when he was 22 and his career took a
hard slide lately Feldman has been
mostly associated with his often bizarre
shots at starting a third act music
career as well as his support for child
sex abuse advocacy groups some of his
more recent acting work has been a
return to the well of us he provided the
voice of slash on the 2013 animated
Ninja Turtles series adolescence is hard
on most people and especially difficult
for reptilian genetic abominations
hence Raphael why why oh I don't know
because I wanted to redecorate you know
a couple throw pillows a TV news
reporter what do you think the Turtles
moody red clad brother was played by
character actor Josh Pais who gets extra
points for not only performing the voice
of Raph but also doing the body work
inside of the seventy pound turtle
costume making him the only one of the
lead performers to do both even if
you're not for me
with his name you've probably seen pices
face the hard-working actor has more
than 90 acting credits to his name some
of his more recognizable roles have been
multi-episode arc Sanh both law and
order and Law & Order SVU
his time as Stu Feldman on ray Donovan
and his difficult to forget turn as the
ill-fated gynecologist in the 2007
horror film of teeth when they come up
with this stuff lately Pisces been
working as the founder and lead
instructor of the committed impulse
acting schools in New York and Los
Angeles
Michelangelo comic relief pizza fishy
annatto and masterful wielder of
nunchucks
Mikey was voiced by child actor Robbie
Rist in the 1990 motion picture nice
night
beats the dude's got 30 seconds a lot of
wrists career has been spent as sort of
a pop culture curse he was hired on as
cousin Oliver for what wound up being
the last season of The Brady Bunch
played booger and the ill-fated Revenge
of the Nerds TV show which was cancelled
before airing and voice rocky and the
Blues Brothers animated series which was
also cancelled before airing luckily
recent years have been kinder to the 54
year old wrist his voice acting career
has taken off and he now has almost 150
credits to his name you might know his
voice from Doc McStuffins where he plays
stuffy or from the 2013 Ninja Turtles
series in which he portrays a mondo
gecko even better wrist was intrinsic to
the creation of the sharknado series in
which he not only played Robbie the bus
driver but also wrote the theme music
speaking of Revenge of the Nerds did you
know that Takashi played the voice of
Leonardo Bryant og born Bryant og Hara
got his start in acting at a young age
one of his first credits was on an
episode of the original Star Trek series
where he played a member of a group of
killer children with an ice cream
obsession it made him a natural fit for
the role of Leonardo in a member of a
group of killer teenagers with a pizza
obsession as with a few other Turtles
alums he's plenty active on the
convention circuit meeting up with fans
and signing out
like a channel maybe somebody ought to
tell him that we're the good guys
yeah any thoughts I've only got one
thought this guy knows where splinter is
Kevin Clash was the voice actor and lead
puppeteer behind splinter the turtles
giant rodent mentor for more than 30
years he was the voice and hands behind
a Connick Sesame Street characters like
hoots the owl and small red tickle
enthusiast Elmo his work even inspired a
documentary about his life 2011's being
Elmo a puppeteers life a quick glance of
the actor's credits over the last few
years shows an uncharacteristic gap
between jobs and the reason is kind of a
giant bummer starting in 2012 some
pretty nasty allegations against clash
began popping up two men came forward
accusing clash of sexual misconduct
the first accuser recanted and all other
cases were thrown out but the damage was
done
clash resigned from his work on Sesame
Street and only returned to the Muppet
life recently working on Brian Henson's
2018 adult puppet comedies a happy time
murders it's not easy to be cool it's
even harder to be cool compared to a
quartet of martial arts cowabunga
monsters that are standing right next to
you
yet somehow Casey Jones always pulls it
off you guys mind telling me what you're
doing my little green pal over there oh
babe in 1990s Ninja Turtles Jones is
played by Canadian actor elias koteas
cotija said a hot streak in the 80s and
90s Landing plenty of roles including
his two best known performances as Casey
Jones in the first and third turtles
pictures and as Thomas Daggett the lead
in the first prophecy movie Cody is a
star faded somewhat during the new
millennium but he still works pretty
regularly recently he had a stellar run
on NBC's Chicago franchise of programs
playing undercover detective Alvin
Olinsky on Chicago Fire Chicago PD
Chicago med and the short-lived ugly
step-sibling of the bunch
Chicago justice in the pantheon of
fiction there are supporting characters
who become as necessary as the
protagonists themselves Luke needed r2
to talk to machines will Turner need a
Jack Sparrow
keep the franchise running a decade past
its sell-by date and the turtles the
turtles needed April presumably because
she had a job and was willing to shell
out the money for pizza every night of
the week
it is really quite simple miss O'Neil in
the original Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles movie April was played by
American actress Judith Hoag relative
unknown at the time Hoke was reportedly
less than thrilled with the direction of
the first film and she's acknowledged
that her personal gripes may have been
what led her to never being approached
to join the sequel you can't keep a good
reporter down though Hogue has gone on
to maintain a healthy acting career with
more than a hundred credits over 30 plus
years recently she had a recurring role
on NBC's reboot of Nashville playing
Tandy Hampton even so April remains
probably her best-known role with Hogue
admitting that she's still recognized
for the part three or four times a week
April O'Neil has had a fascinating life
starting out as a computer programmer in
the comics she's gone on to work as a
reporter of agile on tea and surprise
the fifth ninja turtle with such a wide
range of ever-changing vocations it only
makes sense that her face would change
too when it came time for the inevitable
sequel to Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
the producers decided to go with a new
actress to play April O'Neil this time
they went with Paige Turco an actress
who'd been working on soap operas like
All My Children and guiding light up to
that point
Turco managed to hold on to the part for
both the second movie secret of the ooze
and the third one turtles in time since
then Turco has had a successful career
in television
she had a season long run on NYPD Blue
back in the 90s playing officer Abbie
Sullivan as well as an 18 episode stint
on party of five you can most recently
catch her on CW's the 100 as dr. Abigail
Griffin toca and Rose are may not have
been the most well-received characters
in the Turtles mythos with most fans
responding to the presence with a
resolute wears bebop and rocksteady even
so the performer behind them is a
powerhouse Frank Welker is a pop-culture
Panzer tank who's been tearing through
your childhood memories for decades
without you even knowing
his filmography is so long it has its
own Wikipedia page no we're not
exaggerating god help you if you try to
load the 72 year old voice actors IMDB
page it takes up more bandwidth than
Netflix Welker got his start playing
Fred on Scooby Doo way back in 1969 not
content to simply play one iconic
character he went on to voice brain claw
and the cat unexpected gadget over 20
different transformers Slimer and Ray in
the Real Ghostbusters santa's little
helper on The Simpsons
nibbler on Futurama a whole pile of
Animaniacs Abu Raja and the Cave of
Wonders in Aladdin and no kidding over
800 other roles and believe it or not I
was Smokey the Bear only you can prevent
forest fires
extra crazy he's still playing Fred on
scooby-doo after five decades that's
what you call being committed to your
work check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]